- Good morning Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
worlds major problems.
So to help you on your
journey, today's message
is don't sleep walk through life.
Over to you, Warren Buffett.
(rooster croaks)
♫ I wake up every morning,
espresso keep me going.
♫ I wake up every morning.
- I advise students, as much as possible,
look for the job that you
would take if you didn't need
a job, I mean don't
sleep walk through life.
Don't say it's all going to be great.
I'll do this and I'll do that.
I'm just marking time
until I get to be older.
I've told people that's like saving up sex
for your old age.
(laughter)
It is not a good idea.
(applause)
- [Interviewer] What are
you urging them to do?
- I'll explain just
what I'm talking about.
(laughter)
You really want to be
doing what you love doing.
And you can't necessarily
find it on your first job.
But don't give up before you find it.
- One of the best questions
that you could ask yourself,
period, is if I had all of the money
in the world, what would I do?
Ask yourself, if you had all of the money
in the world, what would you do?
Because when you answer that question,
it tells you what you should
actually be doing right now.
Most people have no idea.
Most people don't know
what they would be doing.
And as a result, people
sleep walk through life.
They're just trying to
their next mortgage payment
or their rent payment, or
just kind of scraping by.
Constantly in survival
mode, sleep walking.
Instead of actually
building something amazing.
I had a recent meeting with
somebody who is on my team
part time and I was asking her,
okay, I asked that question.
If you had all of the money in
the world, what would you do?
And she was talking about
going traveling and bringing
her parents to Canada and buying a house
and all of these things.
I said okay great, that's
done, that's taken care of.
You traveled, you saw all of
the places you want to see.
You brought your parents
over, you bought a house.
You brought your whole family
over, great, all that's done.
And you still have money,
what are you going to do?
I don't know, and that's the problem.
That's the work that you should be doing.
That's the work that if you start doing,
it's going to be able to
give you the money to afford
all of these things that
you want to do in your life.
But as long as your
working for somebody else.
Not chasing your dreams, not
sure of what you want to do.
Not having a plan and just sleep walking.
Then those financial things
that you have in mind are never
going to come true,
you're always going to be
in survival mode and so it's a
good question to ask yourself
at least once a quarter.
If you had all of the money in the world,
what would you do with it?
Because our first instinct
is all of the money things,
all of the things that we
feel that we're missing.
Like the vacation, like
the car, like the house,
like the bills, all of that stuff.
But you still have money
left over, what would you
be doing with your life?
And until you get a really
solid answer then you're never
really going to have a great
plan for where you're going,
in your life and in your business.
If I had all of the money in the world,
I'd be helping entrepreneurs.
I'd be doing what I'm doing.
I would still be making YouTube videos.
I designed my life in such
a way that I haven't had
to make a decision based
totally off of money
for a very, very long time.
I don't take on a great deal
that I don't want to work with.
I don't make YouTube videos
only trying to make money.
Right, I don't do anything
in my life, in my business
just trying to take a cash trap.
And I think it's important.
I think it's important
that when you deep down
understand that this is the
work that you would be doing
regardless of if you've got
pay check for it or not.
If you look at every single
successful entrepreneur
and what drives them, what motivates them,
it's never money, money is
important but it's never
the number one and so I
would strongly encourage you
to ask yourself, at least once a quarter,
if you had all of the money in the world,
what would you be doing
in your day to day life?
And then go out and find
a way to start doing that
right now, it doesn't have
to be some big pipe dream,
it doesn't have to be only
when you win the lottery
or when you sell your business, right now.
Find a small way to get started right now.
Because it's possible
and that's how you stop
sleep walking through life.
So the question of the day today is,
I want you to answer
that question right now.
If you had all of the money in the world,
what would you be doing with it?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Antonio Centeno
from Real Men Real Style,
Antonia thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word
and posting it to your Twitter account.
I really appreciate the
support man and I'm so glad
that you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for a nother shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning,
espresso keep me going.
- The type of person
you are kind of points
to the things that you're good at.
Are you 12, you're not going to know.
Are you 16, you're not going to know.
If you're 18, maybe if you
have a special talent, right.
You know, you can throw a
baseball a 100 miles an hour.
You can sing and your voice
is incredible, you know.
You're a concert pianist,
you're a chess grand master.
If you have a specific skill set or talent
that just immediately
propels you to the top,
yeah, you want to follow that.
But I remember having a
list, I still have it.
When I graduated from
college, I was getting ready
to graduate and all of
the different industries
that I thought I might want to partake in.
When you find something
you're good at, go for it.
I was never really in to
technology when I was a kid
but then as I got a job
that used it, I found out
I was good at it and once I
found out I was good at it,
then it became a lot more fun.
You know when you're good at something,
it's almost always fun.
And once it was fun and
I combined that with my
business skills then I saw,
okay I know how to make money
with this stuff because
I know how to sell.
Now I know tech, that gives
me something I love to do
and so when I tell people
the key is find something
you love to do and be great at it.
- If you're passionate
and you're successful,
you'll wake up one day rich.
You won't really be going for the cash,
it will just happen to you.
Everybody I talk to that's had success,
doesn't remember the day
they became a millionaire.
No idea, not important to them.
They remember winning,
they remember building
a business and being successful.
Again, the pursuit of freedom
manifests itself in passion.
That's really what it's about.
- I do not make any decisions
based on money, none.
It's the worst way to make
a decision, which I know
is so hard to say, I mean I
didn't grow up with any money.
And I know so many of us, our
families have a lot at stake.
They put a lot into us, made
a lot of sacrifices for us.
And you say you don't have
the luxury of doing that,
but I actually think you do.
You will be more successful if
you make decisions based upn
what is going to feed your
soul, make you feel value,
valued, validated, have you
waking up in the morning
and racing to work, whatever it might be.
And I can tell you, after
a short amount of time,
money will not be enough.
At the end of the day, a
bigger pay check is another
suit or more real estate,
more square footage.
That's what it comes down to.
You end up with another
room and a fuller closet
and after a while, that's
not going to do it.